Victim of Homeschooling?
Did I ever tell you that I was homeschooled from K-12th grade?
To this day I have horrible social skills,...
...poor academic skills and almost...
...no ability to reach out and connect with people.
I have never met a "normal" person who was homeschooled...
...and I doubt I ever will.
Oh, and did I ever mention that I've gone to counseling?
It didn't help.
Someone who grew up pampered and rich...
...(which seems to be all the therapists I went to)...
...cannot even begin to understand...
...the pain of the shelter and abuse I've suffered from.
Hannah, there are plenty of homeschooled people out there.
Just because you were homeschooled does not mean your parents were controlling or anything.
They felt that was a better learning environment than the local public schools.
You need to take control and make the changes you want...
...and stop blaming your parents.
They did it out of love for you,...
...not to be intentionally mean.
It's your life, and you need to take charge.